[Music]  beware of false prophets who come to you  in sheep's clothing or inwardly they are  ravening wolves  Jesus is the shepherd who protects you  from those wolves and I am his dog the  sheepdog that get the Lambs back on  track when they stray off the path and  some of you have strayed haven't you  Reverend says he's here to take you back  where he came from  I know you're there and I know you can  hear me you may have no time but there  is nothing wrong with your ears do you  know why I'm here  I'm here to punish you  why do you let him do this it's a sin  I love head  even though it is lost he ain't never  gonna stop is he  I've seen your mother she's the kind of  person that turns the other cheek be  like her  never leave your loved ones alone you  should know that by now son there's just  some things I can't explain  officer Benson down